Hi everybody.
My name's Eric Leichtenschlag,
and I'm here with you today to
talk about AdMob getting
started on Android.
So first we're going to talk
about the prerequisites, run
through a fundamentals example,
talk about how we can
implement AdMob through XML,
then discuss the different ad
formats available in the AdMob
SDK, talk about the different
ad request options you have
when making a request,
listening for ad events so you
know when ads are being
presented and clicked in your
mobile applications, as well
as discuss mediation
and custom events.
So let's get started.
Before running through this
code lab, there are some
prerequisites.
You should have the Android SDK
installed with the latest
system image, 4.2.0 from
the SDK manager.
For development environment
this code lab will use
Eclipse, but you can also use
IntelliJ if you prefer.
You're going to need to download
the AdMob SDK sample
project from our
google-mobile-dev code
project, as well as the AdMob
SDK from our docs.
And it's great if you've read
the Android AdMob docs.
If not, we'll go through
it in this code lab.
And, also, you can optionally
sign up and create an AdMob
publisher account.
If you don't do that, then we
will provide sample IDs for
you to use when testing.
So now we're going to start
with running the
fundamentals example.
The first thing we're going
to do is import our
project into Eclipse.
Import is an Android project
from existing code.
You should have downloaded
this already.
And then we're going to add
the Google AdMob SDK jar
because it's not included
in the sample project.
We're going to set our
project.properties file to
point to the latest Android
versions, so we compile
against the latest
Android version.
We're going to replace the AD
UNIT ID with a sample ad unit
ID or an ad unit ID that you
had previously created when
setting up your AdMob
publisher account.
And these four steps will get
us to be able to run the
fundamentals example.
So I'm going to switch over to
our Eclipse and try to follow
these steps to run
the project.
So the first thing we're going
to want to do is go to File,
New, Project, Android Project
from Existing Code and Browse
and Find the code lab
that we have.
I have it saved on
my desktop here.
And import it.
So there are couple compilers.
One of them is that we don't
have the SDK installed, so
we're going to create a new
folder and label it lbs.
And then we're going to go
grab the AdMob SDK jar.
The latest version right
now is 6.2.1.
I have this on my desktop, and
I'm just going to add it right
into the project, into lbs.
By adding the SDK into lbs,
it'll automatically get
bundled up when I
run my project.
So that should resolve most
of the compile errors.
We're also going to want to fix
up project.properties to
point to Android 17.
That'll change this Android
4.0.3 to compile against
Android 4.2.
And finally, we're going
to fix the ad unit ID.
So let's just go in and copy
the sample ad unit ID here,
stick it in as a string
to our project, and we
should be good to go.
So let's try running this
project and see what we get.
I'm going to run it on a Galaxy
Nexus Jelly Bean emulator.
I believe the simulators not
working so I'm going to quit
this one, and we're going
to try to run it
on this other emulator.
So the app should
be starting up.
Just a basic project, Hello
World, and we should see a
banner coming in here,
and yes we do.
So this is the AdMob test ad.
So that's all it really
takes to get started
with the sample project.
Now let's go back and
see kind of what we
did here to get started.
So this is what the sample
project should look like.
So there are two components here
that are basic, that are
different from the standard
Android project, if you were
just to create a basic
project yourself.
Part of this is altering
the manifest.
The important things to
note here are the
com.Google.ads.AdActivity
required for the AdMob ad to
be shown, as well as with the
proper config changes
displayed here.
AdMob also requires two
permissions, the internet
permission here, of course,
to get the ads, as well as
accessing the network state to
see if internet's enabled.
In the sample activity there's
only four lines needed to
create this banner.
All we're doing here is
creating an ad view.
The ad view is, Extends
From View.
It's just an ad object view.
We're passing in the activity
context, an ad size, in this
case, we're doing a 320
by 50 banner, and our
sample ad unit ID.
The next line of code shows us
grabbing the linear layout
from our sample XML file.
It's assuming we have a linear
layout in XML with ID linear
layout here, and we're just
going to ad the ad view to the
linear layout.
Then we're going to create
an ad request,
just a new ad request.
Here, below this, we're
adding a test device.
This is saying hey, give me
test ads on all emulators.
So that's why we see the test
add on the emulator here,
because we're running emulator
not a device.
And then we're just going
to load an ad
with this ad request.
So that's all it takes to get
started, and you can see that
we have the ad here.
So there's two different ways
to implement AdMob.
I showed you how to
set it up in code.
Now we're going to walk
through how to
set it up in XML.
So you can actually ad a
com.Google.ads.AdView in XML
without any Java code.
In your XML, just specify the
com.Google.ads.AdView, provide
the ad's name space.
And the important properties
here are the ad unit ID, as
well as the ad size.
Optionally, we have
the test devices.
Here I am specifying that
a test emulator again.
You can also specify an ID, test
device ID, to get test
ads on your device.
We'll talk about this
more later.
This is just a dummy
device ID.
Test ads will be white listed
on your device only.
So only the specific device that
you pass the ID for will
get test ads.
Finally, this last option here
says load and ad request in
the on create method.
This prevents you from having
to grab the AdView in code
from the XML and call load
ad with any requests.
It will do it for you.
So let's just copy this XML
implementation and try it out
in our app.
The first thing I'm going to do
is comment out all the code
as a proof of concept to show
that no code is necessary.
I'm going to hop into Res,
Layout, main.XML.
Looks like we already have a
sample implementation here.
I'll just comment this out.
And we're going to run
our project again.
So we're waiting for the project
to be uploaded to the
emulator, and we loaded it up
again, we get a Hello World,
and we get our test ad.
The difference here is that
this was actually a smart
banner test ad.
And we'll kind of talk about
this more later.
There are different
ad formats.
This one here is shown
as a smart banner.
So now that I just showed you
about smart banner, let's talk
about some of the other
ad formats.
From the code we saw the
standard banner.
This is available on
phones and tablets.
The other format that's
also available on
phones is a smart banner.
The smart banner actually
takes up the full
width of the screen.
That's why you actually
saw the test ad here.
It took up the entire width of
the screen, whereas the test
ad we saw earlier in the program
was only 320 by 50,
did not take up the
full width.
Some of the other tablet formats
that we offer are 300
by 250 rectangle, 480 by 60
banner, as well as a 728 by 90
leader board.
So the smart banner behaves
with full width, and its
height is dependent on the
height of the device.
So, generally, for phones in
portrait mode, the height will
be 56 pixels, and in landscape
it will be 32.
And for tablets it'll be
both 90 pixels in both
portrait and landscape.
So these are different formats
that AdMob offers.
Let's talk about some of the
different ad request options
in the ad request class.
So we talked about test
mode already.
AdRequest.addTestDevice, with
the test emulator gets you
test ads on all emulators.
You can also call addTestDevice
with specific
device IDs.
AdMob will hash your
device ID and print
it in log cat output.
So if you want to get a test ad
on your test Galaxy Nexus
device, you would run
the app without any
test device in there.
The logs would say this message,
to get test ads on
this device call
AdRequest.addTestDevice with
some hashed ID.
If you provide this hashed ID in
your code, you'll then get
test ads on your device.
As I mentioned before, you wait
list this specific device
for test ads.
All other devices will
get live ads.
So it is safe to release your
app with this in here.
We prevent you from shooting
yourself in the foot.
There are other targeting
options that AdMob provides.
You have the ability to set the
gender on the ad request.
You can set location
using a suitable
location strategy in Android.
AdMob recommends that you don't
provide location unless
your app already uses it.
Maybe as a maps application,
for example.
Providing location requires
that you add additional
permissions in your app, and if
those are required by your
app alone, then it's
not worth it to add
it in the ad request.
You can also set the users
birthday if you have it on the
ad request, as well as set the
background color and text
colors on the ads.
And this is targeting option
I'll walk through here.
So we're going to try to change
the background color to
blue, and the text color to
yellow by creating a new
AdMobAdapterExtras and adding
these extras to our class.
So this actually needs to be
done in codes, so I'm going to
comment out the XML notation.
We'll hop back to our code.
And on the ad request I'm going
to set network extras
with the new AdMobAdapterExtras
and set the
color background to blue, and
the color text to yellow.
I'm also going to change the
ad size to smart banner
because this will produce
a text ad.
The colors only work on
text ads, image ads
will remain the same.
So since I'm expecting the smart
banner to be a text ad,
we can see the different
colors.
So we're loading the new version
of the app to the
Galaxy Nexus emulator, and we
get our Hello World again, and
we get our full width test ad.
And, as you can see,
it's got a blue
background and yellow text.
The ability to do this lets you
customize the ad so that
it looks better with your app.
If your app has purple
background and yellow text,
for example, you can make your
ad with a purple background
and yellow text and it'll
seem more integrated.
And, overall, it's just a
better user experience.
So that's it for targeting
on the ad request.
Let's talk about some of the
ad events which are very
important when implementing
AdMob.
The AdListener class in the
AdMob SDK has five events.
OnReceiveAd callback let's you
know when AdMob has received
an ad and is about to present
it on the screen.
You can perform any necessary
logic you need to do in your
app when this happens.
AdMob also has
onFailedToReceiveAd.
This happens when AdMob
can't receive an
ad for your ad request.
There are many reasons that
this could happen.
One could be no internet.
The phone that you're running
on doesn't have internet
access, and so we
can fetch an ad.
If you put in your publisher ID
incorrectly you might have
an invalid ad request.
Sometimes AdMob just doesn't
have enough inventory and
can't fill the ad request.
In this case, you will get
the onFailedToReceiveAd
notification.
Just as important are
onPresentScreen and
onDismissScreen.
OnPresentScreen will get called
when the user clicks on
your ad and is about to exit
your app and go to some
overlay or the Google
Play Store.
If you have a game, for example,
and you might want to
pause the game when the user
clicks on an ad, right before
we leave your app we'll let
you execute anything in
onPresentScreen to take
care of this.
Similarly, onDismissScreen is
invoked when the user comes
back to your app after
clicking on the ad.
So maybe you can resume the
game or put up some menu
saying hey, would you like to
continue the game, when coming
back to your app from
an ad request click.
Finally, onLeaveApplication
is very similar to
onPresentScreen.
It just means you're actually
leaving the application versus
presenting an overlay.
So if you were just presenting
an overlay, if the ad
presented an overlay on top of
the app, then you would see
onPresentScreen being invoked,
and onLeaveApplication would
not be invoked.
So they have pretty similar
functionalities.
OnPresentScreen should
he called every time
onLeaveApplication is called,
and is probably the safer bet
if you're trying to
do some pause
functionality or something.
So this is what is contained
in the AdListener.
Let's try to implement
this AdListener
interface in our app.
There are two things
to do here.
First, we're going to have our
banner sample activity
implement the AdListener, and
implement those five methods.
And the next important piece
is to tell the AdView to
listen to these events.
So the AdView that we created
in code, we're going to tell
it to listen to the AdListener
from the banner sample class.
I have a sample interface
implementation here, so I'm
going to copy this
into the app.
It just presents toast messages,
so we can see little
pop-ups in the app.
So the first thing I'm going
to do here is have my class
implement AdListener.
And we're going to want to, on
our AdView, set AdListener
with this class.
Looks like we didn't get all
of our methods here so I'm
going to recopy them.
I seem to have a quick compile
error that I'm
going to fix here.
All right, it seems like copying
from the presentation
is causing some issues.
So I'm going to try to
roll my own here.
We'll just copy one
toast message.
We'll make this onDismissScreen.
OnFailedtoReceiveAd,
onLeaveApplication,
onPresentScreen and finally,
onReceiveAd.
So let's run our app here.
And we should see these toast
messages as the ads come in.
So when we receive our ad, we'll
get this onReceivedAd
toast message.
Let's try clicking the ad this
time, and we should see
onPresentScreen.
So it looks like it's presenting
an overlay here.
I take that back, we get
onLeaveApplication, which
means it's actually going to
the external web browser.
And as we come back to the
app we should get an
onDismissScreen call back.
So if I had failed to receive
an ad I would get this
onFailedtoReceive call back.
So you'll want to override these
methods and implement
them as your app sees fit.
The final thing we're
going to talk about
today is AdMob Mediation.
AdMob Mediation is a feature
that was added a few versions
ago on our SDK.
It allows you to request ads
from other ad networks using
the AdMob SDK interface.
So if you had already signed up
on AdMob.com and created a
publisher account, you could
also create a mediation
placement on
mediation.admob.com.
Here, when you create a
mediation placement, you can
specify which ad networks you
want to mediate with.
In this case, we have
the AdMob network
and AdMob House Ads.
Both set up to serve
50% of the time.
So 50% of the time I'll get an
AdMob ad, 50% of the time I'll
get and AdMob house ad.
And there's actually no
additional code required to
set up mediation.
All that you do is you replace
your AdMob publisher ID with
the mediation placement ID.
So I already have this ID
set up to serve 50%
AdMob, 50% house ads.
Let's try putting that in.
We're going to go back to a
banner request because we set
up the mediation placement
to serve banners.
And let's try running
the app again.
So we're running the app.
We get our Hello World.
It's making mediation requests,
coming back with a
config, and it looks like it
chose AdMob this time.
And it displayed an AdMob
network ad, but it's a test ad
since we specified
testing devices.
I'll leave this as an exercise
to you all to set up your
mediation placement and see if
you can get house ads using
this method.
I should also note that with
mediation you can set up other
ad networks.
All you need to do is include
the other ad network's SDK and
adapter code.
Libraries into your app and
set them up to serve a
percentage of the time using
your mediation placement, and
you should be able to see ads
from other networks as well
without having to integrate
with their APIs.
Another powerful feature
is custom events.
AdMob already supports about 10
or 12 networks, but maybe
the ad network that you're
interested in using is not
directly supported by AdMob.
In this case, you can roll your
own custom event that can
essentially implement one
of these ad networks.
You can also do something
else other than
implement an ad network.
And in this example, we're just
going to create a custom
event that just displays the
Android icon image as an ad
because we don't currently have
another icon in our app.
So let me walk through how
you would do this.
In the AdMob UI, instead of
configuring another ad
network, you would add
a custom event.
You would be presented with this
pop-up that asks you to
include a label, a class
name and a parameter.
The label is just a label
for your custom event.
I called it My Custom Event.
The class name is the fully
qualified class name of the
class that will implement
the custom event.
So in this example, we'll
use com.Google.examp
le.ads.fundament
als.MyCustomEvent.
And the parameter is any
parameter you want to pass to
that custom event for another
ad network that might
be an AD UNIT ID.
In our case, for this example,
we don't actually need a
parameter, so I just presented
the Hello World
screen as the parameter.
So let's implement this example
custom event class.
So here's what it looks like.
There are two methods.
One is the requestBannerAd
method.
In this class you will want
to call out to another ad
network, or grab some view.
And then we're going to call
this CustomEventBannerListener
and tell it we received an
ad and pass in the view
of the ad we got.
Generally, when implementing
other networks, you're going
to request an ad in this method,
and implement the
third party ad networks
AdListener.
And when they see that they
received an ad you would call
Listener or onReceivedAd
with their banner.
In this example, we're just
creating an image view and
setting the Android icon as
the imagery source, and
calling onReceivedAd
with that icon.
The other method that you'll
implement is the simple
destroy method.
If you have any cleanup that's
necessary you'll want to
implement it in this
destroy method.
So let's try this out.
I already have the proper
package here, so I'm going to
create a new class called
My Custom Event.
I'm going to replace the
implementation here with the
implementation from the slide.
And, finally, I'm going to grab
the example, AD UNIT ID,
here for custom events.
I set up this event to serve
100% of the time, so we should
see it here.
So this is our main code.
It's going to load the ad
view with an ad request.
It's going to hit the mediation
server, grab a
config that says I want
to request a custom
event 100% of the time.
The AdMob SDK is going to know
from your configuration that
you want to call in to
com.Google.ads.e
xample.fundament
als.MyCustomEvent and call
request banner ad.
And here we're just going to
return in Android icon.
So let's try running the app
and see what we get.
So we're uploading be app to our
Galaxy Nexus emulator, and
here we have it.
We got a mediation config that
said I want to get a custom
event, and we created our
image view and set the
resource to the icon,
and this is kind of
like our banner here.
You could replace this with a
320 by 50 image and serve
custom ads, perhaps, as a back
fill if no other mediation
works field the request.
So let's make this a little bit
more interesting and an
OnClickListener.
So we're just going to--
when the image view is clicked,
send the user to a
web browser that goes
to www.google.com.
This will also hit the
listener.onclick,
onPresentsScreen, and
onLeaveApplication called backs.
For mediation the OnClick call
back let's the AdMob SDK know
that the ad has been clicked,
and this is used for reporting
purposes in the AdMob UI.
Let's try running this and
seeing if we can click our
Android icon.
So again, we're fetching a
mediation config, calling it a
custom event serving the icon.
We got our onReceivedAd call
back because we notified the
mediation layer that
we received an ad.
And when I click here we should
get the onPresentScreen
and onLeaveApplication
call backs.
Hopefully.
Because we provided them here.
It's important to note that when
implementing your custom
event, you want to send these
messages back to AdMob
mediation as much as possible in
the right places because by
calling onPresentScreen here
in your custom event, your
main app will be able to listen
for it and AdMob can
call onPresentScreen here.
If you fail to provide some of
these callbacks, then your
main app, when a custom event
is shown, it won't get those
call backs, and you might not
be able to pause your game,
and your game might end up
being at a bad state.
So when implementing your custom
event try to call as
many of these Listener
methods as possible.
So just to reiterate, custom
events let you implement any
ad network within
AdMob Mediation.
If the adapters aren't working
you can roll your own solution
using these custom events.
You can implement as many as
you want, and you can do
something else instead
of showing an ad.
Like for example, we
showed this icon.
And there are some or other use
cases that I'll leave as
an exercise for you all to
figure out what you can do
with custom events.
So that's it for
this code lab.
You should be familiar with all
of the important parts of
AdMob, and be able to implement
it pretty easily.
Here are some more resources
in case you need help.
Here's the SDK download
on our Docs page.
Here's the AdMob site
where you can
create an AdMob placement.
We have our developer docs, our
form where you can ask us
technical questions.
You can follow us on our Google
Ads Developer Plus
page, listen in on our Google
Ads Developer blog, check out
our code examples.
And we have a Google Developer
Academy class to help you more
with in depth custom events.
So thanks for watching.
My name's Eric Leichtenschlag.
And I hope to see
you next time.
Bye.